Speaker 1: This is super interesting. In the
moments before it became known that Fox News
and Dominion voting systems settled the Dominion
defamation suit wherein Fox News will pay Dominion
$787.5 million. When it looked like this was going
to go to trial and continue to trial towards the
end. The lawyers representing Fox News threw
Trump and his allies under the bus. And this
is absolutely fantastic. Newsweek reports Fox
News throws Trump under the bus and reads Fox
News. His legal defense appears to have taken
on a new strategy in the company's fight against
a defamation lawsuit by Dominion Voting Systems
for the network's alleged lies about the company
during the 2020 election. Blaming Donald Trump.
Critical element to this, which is a quote from
the article we will put up on the screen. Quote,
The night before the trial's scheduled start,
attorneys for Fox News filed documents imploring
the judge overseeing the case to allow them to
introduce evidence arguing the company's allegedly
defamatory claims against Dominion voting machines
were primarily inspired by Trump's own rhetoric
that the election with Dominion's involvement,
was specifically rigged against him. This is
the similar idea that many of the January six
rioters tried to invoke as their legal defense
when their cases were adjudicated. It's Trump's
fault. Trump told us to riot. Trump told us
to be here, whatever. And then Trump says,
I said peacefully. And that's where the debate
comes from. It's a very similar argument that
Fox News lawyers were going to make. Of course,
the case ultimately ended up being settled. Now,
I want to be really clear and honest with you
about what this is versus what it is not. This
strategy from Fox News saying Trump, It was Trump.
Trump was leading this whole thing. This is not
Fox News finding a moral compass or anything of
the sort. Not even close. This is what Fox News
always does. We've seen so many examples of
it and Alex Jones has done it. Who's separate
from Fox News? And so have many others of these
right wingers. The lawyers will try to come up
with whatever legal argument is best when
they need to do it in a court of law.
It is totally separate from what happens on
the air. For example, when lawyers argued in
court that Tucker Carlson is an entertainer,
he's not a newsperson. He's an entertainer.
He uses hyperbole. He uses exaggeration. You
can't hold him legally accountable for the letter
of everything he says. It might look like a news
show. But fundamentally, Tucker is an entertainer.
And it's not that he's lying. It's that he's using
the stylistic tools of hyperbole and exaggeration.
But the zoom out big picture takeaway here always
is that we have to remember that they want to be
seen as newsworthy and trustworthy in terms
of their public presentation. When it becomes
legally too hot. They step back and say, Well,
that's an opinion show and this is entertainment
and whatever the case may be. That's the same
here when they were doing the reporting. I'm
using language that doesn't even make sense.
It wasn't reporting when they were doing the
propaganda and lies around Trump actually won and
Dominion Voting Systems was part of the rigging
and all these things. They were doing it. Yes,
primarily for ratings. But by presenting it as
if they really believe it, whether they did or
didn't. It's a mixed bag. It seems that Tucker
and Laura Ingraham and HANNITY didn't believe
it, but that Maria BARTIROMO did. Okay. So it
does it doesn't matter. They were presenting it
as news. And then now they want to say, well,
listen, I mean, we were just kind of repeating
this stuff, Trump said. It wasn't so much that
we believed it or that we were trying to defame
anybody. End of the line here is $787.5 million
settlement agreed to by Dominion and Fox News. Fox
News will pay. The Smartmatic defamation lawsuit
isn't over and continues after the break. I
want to dig in specifically to this little
detail that Fox News will not have to apologize on
air for defamatory election lies. Make sure you're
subscribed on the youtube channel youtube.com
slash The David Pakman Show. Quick break right
back. The David Pakman Show does depend on the
support of our podcast listeners, our YouTube
viewers, people who listen on the radio or see
a Tik Tok clip here and there. We primarily
fund our program through the membership program.
You can learn about that at join Pacman dot com.